good so I can use this to find what am I
gonna do with this line okay now if I
want to replace this theta with
something in terms of X I can't actually
do this I could replace I could say okay
well cos inverse of x equals theta and
then feeders up here I'm sorry I could
do that I'm not going to you for two
reasons number one inverse trig makes my
head hurt okay so I'm I'm like trying to
avoid those newbies wherever I can
number two I do it I don't need to I
don't need to because I've got all of
these derivatives to you that I can
relate to chain rule number three I
could put coz inverse Thea because if
it's X there I could but it's not a
function with respect to time it's a
function with respect to X so how you're
going to differentiate that with respect
to the time when the functions not with
respect to time so I could sort of twist
myself to do that but it's learning what
what happens I'm just going to different
here with respect to theta I hope you
can see look carefully at this
derivative I've just written this one
and you can see how it connects to this
one do you see it right because that's
going to get me to my goal yeah it's
gonna get here so I'm gonna say DX mu
theta of the derivative cosine of course
is just okay so now I had this string of
derivatives that I can use now I can get
to DX on DT using chain rule therefore
DX on DT equals I want the DX on the top
and I want my ID theaters to cancel
which is that detail on the bottom and I
have each of these have each of these so
what am I going here I just said that's
quite a son Bo and this is two I've
established that so far okay now pause
for a minute just like when we do excuse
me integration by substitution right we
have to do this like I will introduce
some different variables you change the
boundaries bubbles of law but then we
had to do
like Inception right we had to climb
back out we introduced it because it
helped us do this but this is not what I
want I want DX or DT in terms of X don't
I huh so how will I do is that I can
think of at least two different ways
okay
so let's think about this first what's
going on in red I tell you I have a
right angle triangle here right I have a
right angle triangle so I've got sine
theta where is site leader on this
triangle it's this thing isn't it yeah
it's this link do you create that
because it's it's the y-coordinate right
so I can use this and I can try and work
out this is x over here so I could use
Pythagoras because the radius is one
okay so I know that's why it's this
vertical length so that's how I can use
it in this triangle I'm actually going
to go in this direction and you'll see
why in a second this is okay but I hope
you can see this um this construction is
only going to get me halfway right
because I currently have a right angle
triangle but I'm not going to for long
because what happens when this point
moves over to here like your right angle
triangle it's going to flip over here
and you've got any news another kind of
thing so this is a little bit icky I
look at this and I think caught on
remember how I made this substitution
before I can do this in Reverse right if
I used a parametric definition a
parametric representation to get into
this hole I should be able to use it to
get now does that make sense
so I'm going to say at this point this
thing this is exactly Russian this is
why do you agree that since in x is cos
theta that marries up with Y being
slightly up okay now I'm almost there
I'm this better I back in Cartesian land
now but I know one enters Y a 1 in terms
of X so I'm gonna return to this which
is the original connection
between x and y right this is the
equation of the set how do I make one
subject like that
aha but we began the question by saying
right now I'm just interested in the top
off okay in a second we'll think about
the bottom half but if I'm only
interested in the top half which part of
this pair of equations or what just the
positive one right
y equals I'm on the top half a circle
you could have said that so now I can
breathe this in over here that's the
excellent DT right so therefore DX DT
equals this as requested okay now this
is a follow-up question from this which
will answer in a second but I just want
to stop for a moment and consider what
this means okay um there are some
restrictions on this there are some
restrictions on where density T's this
one of the restrictions X is going to be
what domain restriction is there between
negative 1 and 1
you'd better have that restriction
because that's the only place where the
circle exists oh so fast what else do
you notice about the derivative dose do
you notice about it it's negative it's
always needed because this is where it
by definition is always going to
positive negative times a positive so
the whole thing will always be negative
for all the values else that I can think
about what is that okay because we said
via this things going anti-clockwise and
I'm only interested in the top half no
circle and it's always moving to the
left so the x coordinate is always
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
what would have happen if I went back to
the starter question and said ok now I'm
just interested in the bottom of the
circle what would change
so yeah what will change is at this
point that say whoops wrong semicircle I
put a minus sign here right then when I
bring it back to DX of DT and negative
two over there and the negative here
would cancel leaving me with instead of
utterly negatives only positives because
of course if you're on the bottom half
it's anybody's going to the right does
that make sense there's a couple other
things we can notice and this is going
to answer the next part for us let's
think about some interesting values of X
right you told me there was a debate
addiction so when X is equal to those
extremities right what's the X on DT you
probably wanna leave one key and the
spirit becomes 0 collapses so you get
this now what does that mean what does
this actually tell us about the motion
of this point around the circle
horizontally at x equals 1 and x equals
negative 1 horizontally nothing is
happening it's not moving side-to-side
because of course not
if you look at those exact points for
that split second in time it's only
moving vertically I mean at this point
it's gone up and this points going down
so that's my DX by DT is 0 ok the
question that is Part B is when x equals
0 right what is DX of U TV in this case
okay now what does this be well we were
told right at the beginning that these
things may be able to be teased per
second right so right there at the top I
am looking up here now right here when x
equals zero right all of that 2 meters
per second all of it is thrown into
moving horizontally right no part of
that motion is going up or down right
whereas when we had a look at these
points all that motion is going down or
it's going up right so later on when we
talk about projectile motion what this
is about is what we called resolving
forces right so you throw something
through the air okay kid fact any catch
you throw something through the air
right and assuming you don't throw out
in a straight line like some of that
motion is going up like some of the F I
had to put into is gonna push the object
up and then you throw back here farm if
I thought straight at you thank all the
much is going don't worry my name's not
that good probably get me into motion is
going that vicious that's why I would go
faster of course we go faster right some
Toria at the same effort but all the
motions going in that direction rather
than some of it being invested in
fighting gravity does that make sense so
we were talking a little more detail
about that but this is what's going on
with these numbers this is how you
interpret this on the basis of this okay
so can we just review for a second what
was hard about this question what was
hard about it was that to get from here
given to here the actual question you
had to make a couple of leaps calculus
is no hard as I've said before
differentiation is not much higher at
this it's working out what derivatives I
need and then combining them in
appropriate ways okay so I got asked
that question by a few different people
Leo I hope you work out where your sign
was question I work actually if you
could tell me where went backwards
but this is the way own approach of
question language okay this is really
important this really helps me that this
is again of your essay outline okay it
helps you map out where you get it go so
that this actually makes sense it is a
straight line okay